Scott,
welcome to Google coming in.
Perhaps you could tell us what got you
interested in space. Well, first of all,
I'd like to say it's great to be here.
So great to be anywhere with gravity
because now I can sit down.
Can't do that in space.
It's one of the space station.
I changed position so many times you
would have thought I was running for
president.
Maybe I should have.
So to those of you in the audience that
do not appear to be space alien aliens,
I'd like to say good afternoon until
the rest of you might come in peace.
What I'd like to do first before I talk
about like what got me interested in
becoming an astronaut, I want to read
from the book but a little bit because uh,
you can hear it in my own voice and then
you don't have to go out and buy the
audio book.
I know these are expensive.
Let's start at the beginning of the story.
It's only gonna take about five minutes
and starting the beginning of the story
and uh,
it's really sort of the end of the story
cause I got home and this is about 48
hours after I got back after being on
the space station for an entire year.
I'm sitting at the head of my dining
room table at home in Houston,
finishing dinner with my family.
My longtime girlfriend Ameco now my
fiance in the back of the room and my
daughter is Samantha in Charlotte.
My twin brother Mark, his wife Gabby,
his daughter Claudia,
our father Richie and Amico son Corbin.
It's a simple thing sitting at a table
and eating a meal with those you love and
many people do it every day without
giving it much thought. For me,
it's something I've been
dreaming of for almost a year.
I contemplated what it would be
like to eat this meal so many times.
Now that I'm finally here,
it doesn't seem entirely real.
The faces of the people I love
that I haven't seen for so long.
The chatter of many people talking
together, the clink of silverware,
the swish of wine in a glass.
These are all unfamiliar.
Even this,
the sensation of gravity holding me in
my chair feels strange and every time I
put a glass or a fork down on the table,
there's a part of my mind that is looking
for a dot of velcro or a strip of duct
tape to hold it in place.
I've been back on earth for 48 hours.
I pushed back from the table and struggle
to stand up feeling like an old man
getting out of a recliner
stick a fork in me. I'm done.
I announced everyone laughs and
encourages me to go get some rest,
so I go to sleep. Then I wake up a few
hours later with flu like symptoms,
not feeling very well at all.
I struggled to get up,
find the edge of the bed,
feet down, sit up, stand up.
At every stage I feel like I'm
fighting through quicksand.
When I'm finally vertical, the pain in
my legs is awful and on top of that pain,
I feel something even more alarming.
All the blood in my body
is rushing to my legs.
Like the sensation of the blood rushing
to your head when you do a headstand.
But in reverse, I can feel the
tissue in my leg. Swelling.
I shuffle my way to the bathroom,
moving my weight from one foot to the
other with deliberate effort. Left right,
left, right. I make it to the bathroom,
flip on the light and
look down at my legs.
They were swollen and aliens stumps.
Not Legs at all.
There. No kids in here, right? No
kids, no kids work at Google. Not yet.
Oh Shit.
I say Ameco come look at this.
She kneels down and squeezes one ankle
and it squishes like a water balloon.
She looks up at me with worried eyes.
I can't even feel your ankle bones.
She says it was about 400
pages after that. But anyway,
so how did I get interested in becoming
an astronaut? I want to be in space.
I'm that. Yeah. So you know, I was this a
atypical kind of person,
kid that became an astronaut.
Because when I was younger,
I was a really bad student.
I didn't do well,
not something I'm proud of.
I spent more time looking out the window,
wondering what was going on
outside or looking at the clock,
trying to will it to run faster just so
I can get out of the classroom than I
ever did.
Paying attention in school.
I managed to graduate from high school
in the bottom half of my class and I went
on to college because I was supposed
to go to college. I thought, um,
actually went to the wrong school.
Now I don't mean I went to this school
thinking this one over here was a better
fit for me.
What I mean is I applied to and got
accepted to and showed up here thinking I
was going to this other school,
quite possibly the only person
that has ever done this.
And I get to my college and I'm there
for a few days and I'm like, Hey,
when's the uh, football
game? And they're like,
we don't have a football team.
That's that other school in Maryland.
And I was basically, you know, doing
the same thing I did in high school.
It was impossible for me to pay attention.
I think if I was a kid today,
I'd be the kid with add or Adhd and
maybe I would've gotten a little bit more
help because we know what that is.
I couldn't study, wasn't doing well.
Eventually,
I'm really not even going to class.
One day I just happened to be walking
across the school campus and I go into the
bookstore, the college bookstore to
buy like gum or something. Not a book,
was not a big reader.
I walked into the bookstore.
I happened to see this book on the
end of the shelf. It's got this red,
white and blue cover. It's got a
really cool title, made me pick it up,
not this book made me pick it up and
looked at the back interested enough and
what the bank said that I looked
through it. It took my gum money,
purchase the book,
went back and laid on my unmade dorm
room bed for the next three days and read
the stories of the fighter pilots that
became the test pilots that became the
original Mercury Gemini
and Apollo astronauts.
The book was the right stuff by Tom Wolf.
I think a combination between,
you know,
what these guys were doing and how Tom
wrote in this creative nonfiction way
just captured my imagination.
And I felt like I had a lot
in common with those guys,
the early astronauts and test
pilots that became astronauts, uh,
with one exception. And that is, I was
a bad student. I couldn't pay attention.
And I thought, you know, if I could fix
that one thing, solve that one thing,
maybe I could be like that.
And maybe I could go up and fly airplanes
in the navy, land on an aircraft care.
Maybe if I did well at that,
I could become a test pilot later,
possibly an astronaut. And then,
oh wait, you're thinking, you know,
18 year old kid reads a book, decides he's
going to become an astronaut. You know,
it's kind of science fiction. It's
a, you know, it's a giant leap.
Really what it was. Well, you know,
it started with something very,
very challenging,
very hard,
which was to teach myself how
to pay attention and study.
Once I figured that out, it really became
a bunch of very, you know, smaller,
manageable steps always with,
you know, opportunities to fail,
but always somehow managing
my way back concourse.
And if you consider the that
I read that book at 18, uh,
fast forward 18 years later,
I was 36.
I was flying in space for the very first
time as the first American astronaut
and my class of 35 people to fly.
That's a pretty remarkable comeback.
That for me is even hard to believe.
Thank you. Bye. [inaudible] I know the
whole book is absolutely fascinating. I,
I wanted, um, if you
could talk about suddenly,
I know a lot about the international
space station itself and you spent a long
time, you ended Austin. What's
it like living on the ISS?
Well, it's a, it, there's a few things
about it that, uh, come to mind, right?
It's a fun for one, you
know, you're floating, which,
uh, after you getting over the
novelty of it being fun, it's, uh,
makes most things harder to do. You
know, there's a few things easier.
I always say there's two things easier
to do in zero gravity, moving heavy,
heavy objects and um, you know, getting
in the awkward positions like the hookup,
the Kodak Schaible on your TV.
Much easier when you can
turn upside down or sideways.
Actually I said this to a kid last night
and he pointed out a third thing and he
said acrobatics is also easier.
Absolutely right.
Everything is harder. Um, because you
can't put anything down. No you're lucid.
Even brushing your teeth is hard.
You know, you have the toothpaste,
the toothbrush,
maybe a cap on the
toothpaste and then you have nothing to
do with the toothpaste after you brush
your teeth cause there's no sync.
You can either spit it out into a tissue
which is uncomfortable in zero gravity
or you can swallow it people
half the people do one thing.
I swallowed my toothpaste for a whole
year, which I don't recommend. Um,
you also have an incredible
view on the space station,
but it's a hard place to live and work
when you made me wouldn't be hard for you
guys cause you guys spend
a lot of time at work. Um,
but they make it really nice that
you want to spend time at work. Um,
but when you go to sleep, you're at
work. When you wake up, you're at work.
You can't go outside, no
son, no wind, no rain,
no freedom of choice to do what you
want to do, when you want to do it.
Um, challenging because you're living
in this very risky environment.
You always have to be ready for an
emergency even when you're asleep. Um,
but it's also this magical place.
It's like living in Disney world.
The space station is a very big,
um,
a million pounds size of a football pitch,
a,
uh, internal volume of a really big house.
So you never feel like closed in. Um,
but it's a,
it's a privilege to have spent
for me 500 days of my life there.
And the last time you went back that
year long study was designed to find out
how people cope in space. So we
wanted to go to Mars. How would,
how would humans cut? And, um, you know,
what were the lessons that you
brought back from that? What,
what was the science that
we actually found it.
So this year long mission,
the idea behind it, you know,
many of you might be aware,
we generally send astronauts
up there for about six months.
It's usually like four to five and a half.
It was how the schedule works.
But um,
NASA started talking about sending an
astronaut and cosmonaut to the space
station for a year with the idea of,
you know,
some day we're going to
go to Mars to get to Mars.
It's going to take 200 days to get there.
You'll have to spend a year
on the surface. So, you know,
you're not in zero gravity, but
essentially you're still kind of in space.
You know, Mara or Mars doesn't
have much of an atmosphere.
It's got a third of the gravity of Earth.
A lot of radiation is going to
take you 200 days to get home.
And there are things that
happened to us in space, um,
to our physiology that we need to
understand more about bone loss,
muscle loss affects on our vision
affects on our immune system,
the radiation effects on
us at a genetic level.
So we wanted to study this for a longer
period of time and study it while we
have the space station,
which is an incredible facility to do
science before we lose that in the next,
I don't know, six or so years. Um,
so the idea behind this year long mission
is to someday go to Mars and there was
also a psych component,
so it was a, excuse me,
me and this Cosmin not up on
the space station for a year.
There's also the side study
with my brother and I because
he's an identical twin.
NASA has had the data on him since 1995
he's familiar with how things work.
He spent some time in
space, um, as well. Eh,
he flew four times. He spent 50
days in space. So I would say 50,
compared to my 500
every chance I can show that there's
competition. No, no competition. All um,
yeah.
So the idea behind this genetic study
with my brother and I is to see how the
space environment, the
radiation, the stress,
the micro gravity perhaps affects us
genetically and they have found some
interesting results so far. Right. And
that's a look quite longitudinal study.
I think. Yes, it will go on for the
rest of my life. And uh, you know,
the way Nasa Science
Works is, uh, you know,
it's not driven by like investments and
schedules and trying to get results out
because you're in competition
with somebody else. So
generally takes a few years.
So generally from the
time you collected data,
it's like three to five years to a result.
Okay.
So you would've got to the ice ass a cool.
So tokens through it probably stacks all
of finding out that you're going to be
on a mission.
It was to actually arriving
either facilities or doesn't
see a lot of training.
Yeah. The training that
they would up to. Yeah.
So I became an astronaut in 1996 after
spending time in the navy as a fighter
pilot, flying the f 14 tomcat. Um,
and then as a test pilot in the
navy and then I went on to NASA.
Then for the next few years
I'd be basically to get a
phd and the space shuttle,
because it's the most complicated
aerospace vehicle ever built,
2000 switches and circuit breakers inside,
you know,
some of which have you throw a switch
or push a button at the wrong time.
You blow the thing up, you, your
crew members along with you.
And uh,
yeah.
So I spent most of my time over the next
three and a half years, just, you know,
for this kid that probably had add,
you know,
learning how to fly this most
complicated thing was a challenge.
Like worked really hard at it,
happen to get assigned to my first flight.
Not in a traditional way.
You would think you would come into a
large room and somebody would announce
that, uh, hey, you've been
assigned to this mission.
Congratulations the way I found out as
the commander of the upcoming mission.
I was going to be on this Hubble Space
Telescope repair mission had me, he said,
hey, come in this office,
I need to talk to you.
And I had never really
talked to this guy before.
He was this space shuttle
commander kind of, uh, you know,
had a little bit of reputation. Um, and
he pokes me in the chest and he goes,
you better have your shit together
because we're flying in space in six.
Yes sir.
I'll get my,
I kept my shit together right
away and we trained for,
we wound up flying nine months later
because of some delays, but you know,
pretty soon you're,
you've kind of made terms
with your situation, you know,
you consider the risks that uh,
you know,
after this last accident we had you,
you have a one in 70 chance of dying
on this flight. It was kind of like,
if I took a deck of cards and you know,
left the jokers and all the extra cards
in it, I threw it out in the audience.
A couple decks of cards.
Everyone that got the ace of
spades didn't go home tonight.
And that's how risky it is,
demonstrated risk. And uh,
so you think about that leading up to the
your first mission and even subsequent
missions. Every flight. I always
wrote letters to my family.
I would give them to my brother and then
when I came back he would throw them in
the garbage. And the idea was if I
didn't come back, he would hand them out.
And I did the same thing
for him when he flew.
Pretty soon you're heading up to
the launch pad on your first flight.
Mine was on the space shuttle Discovery
and the launchpad has completely
abandoned, uh, cause the shuttles,
the giant bomb on the top of this hill
fully fueled 5 million pounds of liquid
oxygen, liquid hydrogen,
two solid rocket motors, uh,
places abandoned it.
W it,
with the exception of you and your six
crew mates and a few people that are
going to help you to get strapped in.
And you get in the space shuttle about a
three and a half hours prior to launch,
you get strapped in tight.
You're lying on your back and
your orange pressure suit.
The guys and girls that get you strapped
in and they tell you they bolt the
hatch clothes and take off
and get about five miles away,
clock starts counting down towards zero.
And uh,
you're getting all these
systems ready for launch.
The auxiliary power unit that powers
the hydraulics, the electrical system,
all the different engines,
the main engines that you use for liftoff,
environmental control system, which is
the life support system, the computers,
they all have to be perfect.
Clock gets to nine minutes and it stops.
That's to give you time to catch up if
you happen to be behind and what you're
doing. It's also the time you
think, man, this is really stupid.
Flying into space for the first time.
It's not something you really expect
to ever think you'd do for real. Uh,
at least for me and this kid that couldn't
do his homework. Uh, and then the,
but you can't get away, right?
You're strapped in and hatches,
bolted closed.
Plus you wouldn't want to be the first
astronaut ever run away from the rocket.
I wouldn't look good on the fever.
Now. It'd be a bad thing I am.
That would not be good on your resume.
Ran Away from space launch first ever.
Um,
clock picks up,
it gets to a minute and then 30 seconds
at 30 seconds of space shuttle computers
take over the launch. Um, six seconds.
The main engines light a million pounds
of thrust, but you don't go anywhere.
If you're bolted to the launchpad
by these eight giant bolts,
the clock goes five,
four, three, two, one.
Those bolts are exploded
open simultaneously.
The solid rocket motors are lit and
it feels like the hand of God has just
picked, picked you up off the launchpad
and is throwing you out into outer space.
You feel every pound of that
7 million pounds of thrust.
And I know if you've watched the shuttle
launch on TV or been there in person,
it looks like it's like lifting
off slowly when you're inside.
There is nothing slow about this.
You get the feeling you're
going somewhere, you're not
sure where you're going,
but you know you're not
coming back to Florida.
And after eight and a half minutes,
you are flying around the earth,
that 17,500 miles an hour floating
around the earth and zero g.
Now to contrast this with the shuttle
launch, you know, or the Soyuz launch,
the shuttle and the Soyuz,
I flew twice on the shuttle and then
twice on the Russian Soyuz and the shuttle
was disbanded in,
uh,
2011 was the last flight.
It's like any wife launch to
the ice is now the series. Yeah.
So now our access to space for China
has the ability to launch people.
They don't do it very often,
but you know,
the access to space for the rest of the
world with people is through Russia.
And the Soyuz and the shuttle
are similar in that, you know,
they both launch people into space.
And that's where the similarity stops.
My first Soyuz launch was in 2010 and
then I flew my last Soyuz launch ever
launched in March of 2015 for this
year in space. Mission landed,
um, a year later practically.
And just to contrast,
I'll tell you a little bit
about the Soyuz launch.
So he was a smaller than the shuttle also,
you know,
a bomb on the top of a hill fully fueled
with liquid oxygen and liquid kerosene
is the fuel they use instead of
hydrogen and a you getting a similar,
you get in a bus and head up to the
launch pad with your crew mates saw uses a
bomb on the launch pad on the top
of this hill, just like the shuttle.
But you get up there and
the place is not abandoned.
There's like a hundred people up there
milling around the base of this fully
fueled rocket. All this vapor coming off
the thing and the Russians, you know,
and I, I tell a few jokes,
jokes about the Russians,
but I have a lot of respect
for the cosmonauts and the
people I've worked in the
space program with.
You know,
just different cultures look at
things different ways. And you know,
what's very important to a Russian is if
your friends are going on a long trip,
you're going to be there to say goodbye.
Even if it's at the base
of a fully fueled rocket.
So there are a hundred people up there
and you're just trying to get through
them to get to the launchpad. Some of
them are smoking cigarettes. Swear to God.
You're like,
that guy's smoking.
So you want to get in that rocket as
fast as you can because there's an
emergency escape system up on top.
Thanks.
He had a rocket blow up on the launchpad
and killed like over a hundred people.
Then they still allow smoking up there.
Um,
she get in and it's, it's
cramped, it's loud, it's hot.
You're visors fogging up,
you're all strapped in tight.
A few hours before launch,
there's no countdown clock and the he was,
they didn't seem to need to
put a countdown clock in there.
This was going to be one of the rockets
that like launch nuclear missiles during
the Cold War. After
awhile you're like, Hey,
what time are we leaving?
It's like 10 10 right.
Does that Moscow time or biking or tone?
Eventually someone comes up on
the radio and says ignition,
and I could just picture that guy smoking
just running out there with him with
his light. Half off you the same
question. Yeah. And then you know,
you do lift off slowly in the Soyuz
cause there's no solid rocket motors,
but still within nine minutes you're
flying around the earth at 25 times the
speed of sound. I quite liked you
talked about the rituals, uh, as you,
as you go,
the questions have so many and he seemed
to be what the first time and then when
his dad that keep doing that,
you could talk through a couple of
the stranger ones, you know? Yeah.
The Russians are a little bit more
superstitious than Americans I think by
culture.
But we also have a superstitions in
the u s space program as an example.
After you get suited up and
your orange space suit you, uh,
you play a round of, you play
a card game, low ball poker.
It's got a specific name.
I forget the name of it.
I think I may have mentioned in the book,
but I'm,
the commander of the mission has to
lose or you can't leave the building.
And if he is doing really well it's people
start to get nervous because she was
looking at his clock and you have to be
walking out at a certain time because
you have the schedule, the keep and if
the guy starts keeps winning, you know,
eventually what you do is you kick people
out of the game until eventually it's
just like one on one.
But I've seen people that keep
winning and I not say that. So He's,
my luck is bad luck is, yeah.
Yeah. He has to lose. So he loses,
he uses up his bad luck before you go
to the launchpad and then 18 you'll also
on the launch pad device, then you,
you'll buy locks. Just doesn't matter. Oh,
but yeah, the commander represents
the whole crew, so yeah.
Yeah.
It's just about him.
I don't think it really matters if he
wins or loses to be honest with you.
But it's tradition. Um, and
the Russian space programs,
also traditions.
We always watched the same movie,
the white son of a desert or something.
That's a comedy because they
had an accident in the Soyuz.
The next crew watch that movie and
they never had another accident,
so there'll be watching that movie all
the way until they have another accident.
Hopefully not.
We also stopped the bus on the way to
the launch pad and the same exact spot.
Yuri Gagarin stopped the
bus because he had to pee.
So we get out of the bus,
we undo our pressure suit.
That's just been pressured check
to extensively pressure check.
We break the Seal and we pee on
the bus tire in the same spot.
Yuri Gagarin and the FEMA national
experience more buffalo with them as well?
Yeah,
they bring a bottle.
I've heard they spray their water or
in some cases urine if they're really
superstitious.
They brought some of their own urine with
them so they don't have to completely
get out of the suit. You know, it's
funny though, people are like, wow,
you do that pressure check and you spend
all that time to make sure the suit
suit works and is sealed and then you
just go and do the whole thing and get
into the soil. Soy Use. They say, I can't
believe the Russians do that. And I go,
we do the same thing in the u s we
just have a bathroom on the launch pad,
the last toilet on earth.
And if you're leaving earth,
you're going to be your damn well
going to use that last toilet.
So you do the same thing. You
get out of your suit, you pay,
you put it all back on getting the shuttle
and go. That's great. I mean lunch.
That's awesome. That's
great. Um, well, uh,
I'm sort of interested
with your given space.
How did you cope with the isolation as a
parent in the book where you talk about
you were the only person in the u s
section? Yeah, I mean it started, did,
it starts off as a few.
I've got the ads myself that will space.
Is isolation trading
something that you get taught.
It's not something they teach you.
They,
they definitely make sure
you're not like cluster phobic.
When you do the astronauts selection,
they'll actually, you know,
hook you up with a heart monitor,
put you in a small rubber bag,
thick rubber bag,
zip it up and push you into
a dark closet and leave you.
They're not telling you how long
you're going to be in it. And uh, he,
there's no way you can fake not being
claustrophobic and that environment.
But they do check that, you
know, I, we had a nap. He
like, yeah, I got all asleep.
It's not, it's not. Yeah.
But I was fortunate in that I flew for
six months before I flew for a year,
which is good training for a year in space
cause I knew what I was getting into.
I actually liked being on the US side
of the space station by myself. Um,
not that I don't like
the people on there with,
but it's just easier in a lot of
ways. It's very quiet. It's peaceful.
When you put something somewhere,
you know it's going to be there when you
come back and have a very orderly. Um,
so actually on this last flight,
I was alone basically on the US side of
the space station for about six weeks.
Okay. Yeah, it wasn't bad. I liked it. Um,
and uh, but to answer your full question,
how do you deal with the isolation?
You have good connectivity with Earth.
I mean, you could make phone calls,
you have email, you have video
conferencing capability. I mean,
people are amazed at the, uh, the ability
we have to communicate with the ground,
which I find fascinating
that people are shocked.
You can have email and space. I'm like,
yeah. You know, satellite communication,
satellite, satellite, I
mean with the Internet,
I guess social media plays in
increasing part and an astronaut,
that public perception thing. Did you
use social media the on I did. You know,
um,
before I launched,
President Obama invited me to the
state of the Union address and he, he,
uh, during the address he challenged
me to Instagram the experience.
So, of course I tried to do that as best
I could. I actually thought it felt like,
you know, engaging with the
public with the, you know,
social media was kind of a responsibility,
you know,
the public pays for this program and
to keep them involved is important.
It was also good for Ameco and I in our
relationship for us to have something,
it was kind of like a personal
project to do that had, you know,
daily feedback in how
well you were doing at it.
With like Mika worked in
payoff when I said yes,
she worked at the NASA public affairs,
although they made her do this as a,
you know,
outside of her work hours,
which is hard to believe that
that was the case. But yeah,
so I tried to engage the public.
I often would have in my free time do
some like tweet chats and things. One day,
actually I'm answering questions on a
Saturday on Twitter and President Obama,
um, asks a question, he says, Hey Scott,
do you ever look out the window
and just freak out? And I'm like,
no,
Mr President.
And I don't really freak out about
anything except getting a Twitter question
from you.
Within seconds,
Buzz Aldrin jumps into the
conversation and he says,
Mister President,
he's only in low earth orbit.
I went,
I went all the way to the moon.
So I got trolled
while I was in space.
By the second man on the moon. It's like
the greatest thing that's ever happened.
Um, what's your next big challenge?
I mean, sort of, you've, you've,
you don't going back
into space because Emily,
that's that part of your
life is finished now.
You'll still have an involved in NASA.
You'll on the bolt to decide who the
next program I call my next big challenge
tomorrow. Okay. Yeah. But she has
been going one day after another,
especially when writing this book.
We've been on this book tour since
October 16th with one day off on the
weekends. Um, you know, it's challenging
coming back after a year in space.
You don't feel well,
it's hard to adjust back to life
without this very stringent schedule.
I went from being a government employee
for nearly 30 years to basically a,
an employee like uh, uh, I forget, I
don't even know what the right term is.
A small business owner
with you know, dots. Yeah.
Like a consultant and had to establish
like very quickly to like kind of high
end keynote speeches. I wrote this
book which took like 18 months,
wrote a kids book,
did the Audio Book,
signed 27,000 Tippins for this
thing, you know, all these things.
This has been one after
another after another.
So that come January I'll start to
start to think harder about like,
what do I really want to do for the
next, you know, five to 10 years. Yeah.
Well I'd love to take some questions.
Maybe I'll work for Google. We,
I'm sure we would love to have you.
So have a think about some questions
and we'll pass the mic around.
I've got one more. Are you talking
to me? Let me think of this.
So speaking and Google.
So I'm in Russia and I'm
the head of the national,
so office and Star City and my,
I was like the lead Nasa guy there and
the guy who's like the safety engineer,
he says to me one day, he goes,
hey, I want to show you something.
He opens up his computer
and he says,
see this? And it was a little
rectangular window. And I said,
Google underneath. He said, see this,
you should invest all your
money in the right now.
And I'm looking at it and
I'm like, man, I don't,
yeah.
How wrong was
I? You talk about, uh,
being in the astronaut office and being
surrounded by these great astronauts of
the history of which one
was Senator Glenn. Yeah.
I view ever thought about going
into politics is that it's not a,
is that something you'd be
interested in? You know, I think
I would have a lot to contribute.
The problem I have is, um,
well, there are a few problems.
One is that I'm neither a
Democrat or Republican, you know,
in the u s some,
I'm not a registered independent,
but I voted for Republicans.
I've voted for Democrats.
I'm kind of in the middle on some issues.
I look like a Republican and
others I look like a Democrat,
but the bigger problem is
in the United States, and I,
you guys might not even understand
this because this is a uniquely a us,
perhaps a uniquely us thing,
but we have two things that prevent
moderates from a winning elections.
Uh,
one is called gerrymandering.
Gerrymandering is when you create a
political district that includes all the
people of one party and you've,
what you do is if you're that party,
you sue the government to say,
I'm going to take this swath,
and it's going to be mostly Democrats,
mostly Republicans.
And the people in the United States that
run in the primaries are the hardcore
people in the party. They're the
extreme right? Or the extreme left.
And if you're running in one of
these gerrymandered districts,
if you're a Democrat and you're running
in a gerrymandered Democrat district,
you have to be on the left side
of the party, the extreme left.
Likewise the extreme
right for a Republican.
So you can't even get on the ticket
unless you're an extremist. And the key,
you either have to be an extremist
or you have to be a very clever liar,
you know, you have to make,
believe you're on the extreme,
then somehow it's pivot to the
center. Very, very hard to do.
So it doesn't make uh,
the situation,
um,
you know,
acceptable for or workable
for people that are moderates.
Um, we have an independent
party in the United States,
but it's not one that's ever been very
successful because of things like this
thing called citizens United
citizens United was a lawsuit,
but it allows corporations to give
unlimited amounts of money to political
action committees that support
candidates. So basically, you know,
you become behold into these donors that
are giving you tons of money and if you
don't want of, um, the
somebodies, you know,
working for some corporation when you're
really supposed to be representing the
people, it's hard to win. But
you did vote from space. I voted.
It was that planning process.
Yeah. Yeah. Pretty easy.
I didn't have to wait in line, just
pumped about it. Gap Questions.
Must be questions. Yeah. This
is kind of microphone on you.
All right.
Thank you so much for coming to visit us.
Really appreciate that question
about the Hubble telescope. Uh,
how was it, uh, how was it
to work on? What's it like?
So yeah, my first flight was to
huddle and it's uh, it's really big.
It's like the size of a school bus,
maybe bigger.
One side of it that you rarely see is,
um,
I don't know why you really see this side,
but once I'd always faces the
sun just kind of like burnt,
burnt to a crisp almost.
And um,
but it's amazing to see a,
uh,
an instrument that's been out in space
for so long that has shown us more about
at least the general public,
more about the universe. Um,
then anything else ever.
Um, so I really enjoyed,
uh, working on it. I didn't,
I didn't do any of this space walks
because I was a pilot of the mission.
We actually launched right before y
two K on this flight and December.
And NASA had us land early cause they
were worried that the computers on the
space shuttle,
we're going to divide by zero and we're
going to go through some worm hole
end up on the other side of the galaxy.
I'll have to wait another thousand years
to see if that would have happened. You,
you take it, see the outside of the
space station quite a lot. And was that,
you discussed how,
talk about how that was kind of,
you'd be seen a tiny
asteroid will pop off.
You had the opportunity on this flight
to do a three space walks. I'd never,
never done a spacewalk before because
as a pilot or commander of the space
shuttle,
you just don't do them because it's risky
and you're a critical to landing the
spacecraft safely. The mission
specialists are more expendable.
Um, but yeah, going outside for the
first time is pretty, pretty crazy.
Um,
neither of us had done a spacewalk before,
so I was the more experienced guy.
So I got to go out first and open the
hatch and you open the hatch and earth is
250 miles below you and
you're going 17,500 miles an
hour and you're making sure
your,
for one it's hard to get out because the
suit and the whole that is the hatch or
like almost the exact same
size. So, and it's square,
the suit's kind of square.
But this hatch is round.
It's like putting around a
square peg in a round hole.
It has to be perfect to get out.
And it feels like at first you're kind
of climbing down with your head down
towards the earth.
Although you know you don't have gravity
so you don't physically feel like
you're upside down, but visually
you feel like you're upside down.
It was interesting when I got halfway out,
all of a sudden my orientation,
my reference frame shifted.
So now all of a sudden I felt like I was
climbing out of the sun roof of a car
and there was this alien
planet over my head,
like in a science fiction movie,
like right there.
And I felt like I was on earth and there
was this alien planet and the look like
it was just going to come
crashing down upon me. Wow.
But I had to really focus so I didn't
like lose anything or very distracting.
That kind of situation.
I think you talked about if you've lost
focus and I went no longer tethered to
the [inaudible] U.
Dot.
S You'd done w if you are a model an inch
away as well, you know, in the u s suit,
we do have a,
a jet pack that has a little bit of fuel
that you could potentially fly yourself
back if you became detached.
Um,
it's challenging to use. Often when
you're practicing this in a VR situation,
you don't Miss, you miss the station
altogether. And in those cases,
you know, if you're an inch
away and you can't reach,
you might as well be a mile away.
The results are still the same. Wow.
He's got the microphone.
Yeah.
I'm interested, um, say hey,
what the experience is once she returned
to us off to you're in spice and was it
how to, to kind of readjust from
the mental or physical perspective?
Yeah, so there's, you know, there's,
I think two general adjustments.
There's the physical and the
psychological part physically.
You know, at first you're, you're
nauseous. Although, you know,
I didn't throw up this time. I threw
up after six months. Surprising.
I didn't throw up after a year. I
wish I could have, but I couldn't.
I would've felt a lot better
if I to just puking my guts up.
I don't know if some of you ever saw
pictures of me coming out of the,
out of the soil. You sum it up. If there's
one, I'll find one. Yeah. But anyway,
I had this, you get essentially saying
that UK book has different pictures,
but I had this big um,
big smile on my face when I got,
when I landed and it was not because
I was feeling well because I wasn't,
I was just trying to look better
than the two guys I was with
was actually hoping to
get an academy award.
But I understand they sometimes make
mistakes so maybe next time I fly in space
for a year, he talked about
that day [inaudible] to Chaz
for the Russian doctors.
As I said, anybody wants to kind of
walk. If you had to, you wouldn't walk.
Well the first time I started
walking I make a comment.
There's actually this PBS special that
just came out and they actually show the
video of me and the tent doing some post
flight test right after I got back and
I say something like, Y'all, I'm
walking and I'm like going like this.
Like I'm walking like jar jar
Binks felt like jar jar Binks.
But you for the first few
days, you're sore, your joints,
your muscles are stiff.
I had a,
I was nauseous for a week
anywhere my skin touched anything.
I had rashes and hives
for a couple of weeks.
Like I said in when I was reading, when
I stand, stood up, my legs would swell,
I could actually see him swelling, no kid
and just like us dealing all the blood,
just infusing in the bottom of my legs.
It was like, and this is not good.
Um,
and how long did that take to get?
I would say the physical stuff
completely. A couple of months. Okay.
The mental part of it,
probably more like eight months.
Because you live in this very controlled
environment where you have a schedule
that you are following, you
know, every five minutes.
Now sometimes the blocks of time that
are dedicated to your activity are 10
hours. If it's a spacewalk other
times, if it's throw the switch,
it's five minutes.
But you were following that every,
all the time for a year. And then when
you get home you don't have that anymore.
And I both times after my long flights,
I would find myself just sitting
on the couch with all this stuff.
To do, but because no one was telling
me when to do it or what I had to do,
I just sat there and it took a
while to readapt to living on earth.
There are actually some good physical
things about being in space for a long
time and that is when you, uh,
when you don't use your feet,
all the calluses, they fall
off. It takes a few months.
It's kind of disgusting when you take
your socks off and you get this big
cloud of foot Dandruff,
you never want to take your socks off in
the vicinity of one of your crew mates.
But then when you get, you know, after
a few months you have these baby feet.
And I,
after my first long flight when no one
knew who I was and that it was up there,
like two days after I got home,
I went to get a massage and one of these
commercial massage places you at the
end of the massage, they rub your
feet, ladies rub my feet and she says,
you have the softest feet I've
ever felt in my entire life.
All I said to her was, thank
you, I'm very proud of them.
And then I left.
He's probably till still talking
about that bald guy with the song.
I think a question of hat
you've given the unique getting insane.
What can we Russians and then
I'd like to ask you about a,
how would you like to see that those
are the future of collaborations with
Russia in the meant fight? Yeah. Yeah. I
think our space cooperation with Russia's
is a great example of how to countries
that at times we're enemies,
sometimes not friends often conflict,
but how we can work together
in this international
program for something that we
both believe in,
feel strongly about and do
it as a team and in space.
Uh, even on the ground working,
preparing for space flight,
any kind of conflict that we ever had
our governments ever had does not affect
our working relationship. You know,
we are friends, we are colleagues.
What is more important to us is supporting
one another. Our personal safety,
you know,
we have to rely on each other sometimes
for our lives that any issues between
our countries. We never really even
discuss much. Sometimes you do.
Like when I was on the space station,
it's when Russia moved into Syria and
there was real concern that pretty soon,
um, due to some kind
of accident, you know,
the u s and the Russian military would
have get into some kind of skirmishes.
Fortunately that never happened.
We talked about that on the space station,
but it almost, we were talking
about a kind of in an abstract way,
like we were talking about not
the United States and Russia,
but like China and Germany.
Um,
and then we just realize,
hey,
this is on earth and
we are in space and um,
that those issues don't
really translate up here.
Misha Kornienko, Mikhail
Kornienko, my, uh,
Russian brother from another mother
that I spent a year in space with.
He said he would say a few times
during the, he says, you know,
if our country's ever want to solve
their issues, we have with one another,
all we need to do is put our two
presidents in space for a year together.
Although those two guys
might like it too much.
I just take one this table if in the back.
Hello. Very nice work. Congratulations.
So w we are computer science,
right?
So whenever you watch a movie and
there's a computer guy doing stuff,
we look at that. So yeah, that never
going to happen. That's not like that.
How do you feel when you watch
films like interstellar and Marsha,
the Martian gravity, all these
kinds of movies from space that we,
from our point of view, oh that
looks amazing. Might be like that.
How do you feel about it?
Well,
I watched all of those movies in space.
You mentioned gravity. Yeah,
maybe not interstellar,
but I definitely watched the Martian
and gravity in space. I actually,
they sent us the Martian and a
couple of days before it, uh,
it came out and we watched it
like a preview. I actually talk,
talked to Matt Damon on the phone a couple
of days before it came out and he was
interested in what we were doing.
It seems like he knew about as much,
he knew him as much about spaces.
Maybe George Clooney does.
But uh, yeah, the Martian was
pretty accurate. I think, you know,
there was things, there are always
things that are wrong with these movies.
Like you know,
that storm they had on Mars,
there's like no atmosphere on Mars.
You wouldn't have something
like 800 mile an hour.
You might have an 800 mile an hour wind,
but it's not going to knock anything over,
you know, because there's no air. Um,
and the other thing that was weird with
the Martian as they always called the
commander and the female
commander on the rescue ship,
they would call her commander.
We're on a first name basis
and then gravity, you know,
gravity has got all kinds of technical
problems with it, but it's exciting,
exciting movie.
Um,
I think it's good that they took that
licensed to make it really dramatic.
We watched it on the space station and
had this screen set up in the a node.
One of the space station, which is a
u s laboratory module is in the back.
And um,
it's Kinda like watching a movie of your
house burning down whilst while you're
inside of it.
But there is the biggest regret of my
whole year in space was we're watching
that movie and Sandra Bullock in this
scene with our short dark hair is floating
through the lab module in her underwear
and Samantha Christopher ready,
this Italian astronaut woman with her
short dark hair comes floating by in her
like Spandex,
like gym shorts.
She ran in and a tee shirt looking
exactly like her and I'm thinking I got to
get a picture of this and then I didn't
because I felt like weird about it
because you know she was in her gym
clothes and Sandra Bullock was in her
underwear.
But it would have been the,
they would have been the the biggest
tweet ever from [inaudible] base.
You actually,
I think you talk about,
I talk about that in the book compared
with not Watney unfavorably when you,
you let some flowers. Yeah, we didn't
let the flowers and the system has some,
if I was just, shit was just following
national rules on taking care of,
we grew some vegetables,
a lettuce in space and we
grew some Zinnias flowers,
which apparently you can eat but you
don't eat them. The idea being if you can,
you know, grow a flower, you can grow.
Maybe something like a
tomato that was grown,
these flowers and just following
the directions, water them,
don't want it in a mortar them.
There was so much time delay in the NASA
system of looking at the photos about
the condition of the flowers.
When they would tell me to water them,
they would be almost dead. When they
would tell me to stop watering them,
they would be covered, they would
be wet and covered in mold. Um,
and I was fine with that because it was,
it's not my experiment.
I was just doing what I was told.
And then one day I post a picture of
the flowers and some guy comes up and he
says,
you are no mark Watney
fight was on then. And then I
told [inaudible], I said, okay,
if you want these flowers to live,
you're going to have to just let me
decide when to one of them because there's
too much time delay in the system.
So I started like touching him and brought
him back to life and got them really
nice.
Occasionally I'd take them down to the
Russian segment and put them on the duct
tape on their table is a
little centerpiece when we
were having dinner and they
got a lot of attention and
people like the flowers.
One day Sir gave all cough Russian
guy system and he goes, Scott,
why are you growing these
flowers? And I say, I say,
Sergei, we're growing these. So
if we can grow these flowers,
maybe we can grow something
that's more nutritious, uh,
that we can eat to supplement our
nutrition on the space station.
Especially if we're going to Mars
and go, the plan is, you know,
we grow these flowers, then we can
grow tomatoes that we can eat. He goes,
why would you want to grow tomatoes? And
there's just so we can eat them. He goes,
you should grow potatoes,
you can live on potatoes,
you can't live on tomatoes
and you can make vodka
is a great guy. Uh,
wait, one more question.
Yep.
Hi. Thank you very much for
your talk. Very inspiring. Yeah.
Can you show some thoughts about the
potential of building a colony on Mars?
The necessity,
feasibility and maybe even timeline.
Hmm.
What about journey to Mars?
Yeah, a colony to Mars. You know,
I was asked a question when I was on the,
on the space station by a
reporter and the question was,
now that NASA has determined that there
was liquid water on Mars sometime during
the year, will that help us get
there any sooner? That, I don't know.
Maybe now if we found money on Mars,
that would help us get there real quick
because that's what we need is money.
Right. My brother often says, you know,
go into Mars is not about rocket science.
It's about the political science.
You know,
I think we know a lot of what we
need to know too. Get the crew,
a crew to Mars to support
them on the surface.
It's just going to be really expensive.
And to do that you need,
you know,
representatives in government that are,
that are science minded people
that believe in science. Um,
we don't have enough of that in
the United States. So, um, I think,
uh,
US getting to Mars is doable.
I think it's doable today, but I don't
think it's going to happen anytime soon.
Um, because at least in
the u s government, I mean,
my concern is less about going to Mars
than it is about members of Congress,
not believing that 97% of the experts,
scientists,
um,
are correct when they say
we are responsible for in
some ways responsible for
climate change. That's a bigger
concern of mine. You know,
when you have people that are not,
uh,
don't come from a technical
background and can say,
I disagree with all these experts.
I mean that's,
that's arrogance to an amazing degree
that we have to get past that before we
can do anything like
going to Mars someday.
Do you think that it's, I, I
have one more question on them.
Commercial space travel so we can
kind of virgin galactic and space x,
the space toys and seems
to be inching ever closer.
Do you think that whatever would use
the whisk enough that that will happen?
You talk about the one in 70 odds,
you know,
do you think that's where the risk
lies? Absolutely. You know, absolutely.
I think we are on a cusp
of, of uh, you know,
technological advances that uh,
you know,
whether it's in space flight
or self driving vehicles,
self piloted cars. I think, you know,
we're kind of getting into a revolution,
you know, certainly with space flight,
you know, it's going to be risky.
People will die just like in the
early days of aviation. But, you know,
hopefully within our lifetimes
you're gonna be able to, you know,
hop on a rocket powered
airplane or whatever you want
to call it and be a in New
York in 30 minutes,
which would be really cute.
Would you be fest fest in line for that?
Uh, it depends on how much they paid me.
Okay. Yeah. Let's take one more question.
I think there's one more question then
I want to just leave you with a final
thought. Great. I'm not at
the back. Thank you. Um,
so my question is like,
thinking about your entire career from
first day at school to first time flying
on your own first time in space,
doing a space walk,
like what was the biggest
jump in scariness and did
the previous jumps help you
with that? That's definitely
a career. Yeah, definitely.
Building Block. I, you know,
I would say the scariest thing I've ever
done is landing on an aircraft carrier
at night. You know, half the time it's
terrifying. The other half is just scary.
Um,
the most like holy shit moment though
would be the first time you fly in space
in those solid rocket motors light and
you feel every pound of that 7 million
pounds of thrust.
And that's more than a holy shit moment.
That's like a holy something else
moment where it is so shocking that,
and so surprising and so
unexpected that when I,
I flew my first flight like three years
before my brother ever flew into space.
So I had three years to explain to
him what that was going to be like.
And he was a combat pilot for the
[inaudible] and the Gulf War test pilot,
same astronaut class basically,
you know,
same DNA is me.
I tried to explain that to him when he
landed and the hatch opened and he came
out of the shuttle. The first thing he
said to me, I was waiting right there.
He said, I had no idea what that
was going to be like. None. I mean,
that is how amazing.
Absolutely amazing it is.
Thank you. So before we leave, yeah, fine.
I'd just like to leave you all with a,
you know, one final thought on my, uh,
my experience in, in space and that is,
you know, when I was leaving the space
station, this is a space station.
I spent 500 days of my
life on over three flights.
I flew my first flight to humble.
It was a week.
Second flight was two weeks,
third flight, 159 days.
Fourth flight was 340.
Some smart guy told me that's
a second order polynomial.
If you graph it, if I fly in space
again, I don't really come back.
It goes asymptotic almost.
Maybe it's like a five
and a half year mission,
but I'm leaving the space station.
I'm looking at this thing out the window.
What I can see from the little
window and them thinking, you know,
we built this thing a million pounds
the size of a football field or pitch
football pitch while flying around
the earth at 17,500 miles an hour in a
vacuum,
in extremes of temperatures of plus
minus 270 degrees built with this
international partnership of 15
different countries, different cultures,
different languages,
different technical ways of doing things,
put together by astronauts and cosmonauts
in space in these difficult to work
space suits,
connecting these modules,
some of which had never touched each
other before on our first time they ever
met was in space.
This is the hardest thing we've ever done.
Absolutely convinced of it. Harder than
going to the moon and if we can do this,
we can do anything. If we want
to go to Mars, we can go to Mars.
We want to cure cancer and put the
resources behind it. We can cure cancer.
We want to fix our problems with the
environment. Challenges in my country,
in the United States,
which there are many.
I think they are all solvable challenges
you guys have in your industry,
in your country here,
or wherever you may come from.
I was absolutely inspired after spending
a year in space that if we can dream it,
we can do it. Thank you very much, ladies
and gentlemen. It's called [inaudible].
[inaudible].